aussi invraisemblable soit-elle,
prend des airs de vérité.
Il n'y a pas que les enfants
qui soient capables d'atteindre ce rivage.
Les adultes aussi, quand nous lisons.
Voilà pourquoi, dans deux jours, vous irez à Dublin,
pour faire le tour de Bloomsday à pied,
et voir tout ce qui est arrivé à Ulysse,
même si rien n'est vraiment arrivé !
A Londres, les gens visitent Baker Street,
l'appartement de Sherlock Holmes.
Alors que le 221B a été peint à cet effet
sur une maison qui n'a jamais eu ce numéro.
On sait que les personnages sont fictifs.
Mais on a des sentiments réels pour eux.
C'est notre don :
on sait que les personnages ne sont pas réels,
tout en sachant qu'ils le sont aussi.
C'est plus facile pour les enfants que pour les adultes.
J'adore écrire des histoires pour les enfants,
parce qu'ils sont les meilleurs lecteurs
de fiction littéraire sérieuse.
Quand j'étais gosse,
j'étais obsédé par les romans avec des portes secrètes,
comme « Narnia »,
on ouvre une garde-robe,
pour passer dans un monde magique.
J'étais convaincu que les portes secrètes existaient,
et je les cherchaient pour les franchir.
Je voulais vivre et atteindre le monde fictif.
En fait, j'ouvrais toutes les portes des placards chez les gens.
(Rires)
Chez le copain de ma mère,
il n'y avait jamais de monde magique.
Il y avait juste plein de choses bizarres.
Je pensais que maman devait être au courant.
Et je me faisais une joie de lui raconter.
(Rires)
Après mes études, mon premier job
était derrière une de ces portes secrètes.
Cet endroit s'appelle 826 Valencia.
C'est son adresse, 826 Valencia Street,
dans Mission à San Francisco.
Quand je travaillais là,
il y avait une maison d'édition
appelée McSweeney's,
un centre d'écriture sans but lucratif, le 826 Valencia,
et sur la devanture,
il y avait un magasin étrange.
Ce quartier était marchand par décret,
et la ville de San Francisco n'est pas flexible.
Alors, Dave Eggers, l'écrivain qui a fondé le centre,
a ouvert un magasin pour pirates
pour respecter le code.
(Rires)
Et voilà.
C'est super beau, en bois et tout.
Il y a des tiroirs à agrumes,
pour éviter le scorbut.
(Rires)
Il y a des bandeaux de couleurs,
parce qu'au printemps, les pirates se lâchent.
Incroyable !
Le noir, c'est ennuyeux. Du pastel !
Des yeux en verre de toutes les couleurs,
pour gérer toutes les situations.
(Rires)
C'est étrange mais, il y a des gens qui venaient
au magasin et achetaient des choses.
(Rires)
Cela permettait de payer le loyer
de notre centre d'éducation dans l'arrière-boutique.
Le plus important selon moi,
c'est que la qualité de notre travail
d'éducation des enfants à l'écriture,
est affectée positivement par le fait
que nous devions traverser cet espace fictif, étrange et liminal.
C'est notre porte secrète à traverser.
Donc, j'ai géré le 826 de Los Angeles.
J'ai dû construire le magasin.
Et voici « l'Agence de Voyage dans le Temps d'Echo Park ».
Notre slogan : « Quand que vous soyez, nous y sommes déjà ! »
(Rires)
La boutique est sur Sunset Boulevard, à Los Angeles.
Notre personnel sympa est à votre service.
Ils viennent de toutes les époques,
même des années 80 ; celui-là au fond,
il vient d'un passé très récent.
Nous avons les « Employés du Mois »
dont font partie Genghis Khan et Charles Dickens.
Des personnalités éminentes sont passées par chez nous.
Voici notre rayon pharmacie.
On a des médicaments brevetés,
des vases canopes pour vos organes.
Du savon communiste où il est inscrit :
« Ceci est votre ration annuelle de savon. »
(Rires)
Notre machine à boue a cassé
le soir de l'inauguration,
et on ne savait pas la réparer.
Notre architecte était couvert de sirop rouge.
On aurait dit qu'il venait de tuer quelqu'un.
Ce qui aurait pu arriver,
dans le cas précis de cet architecte.
On ne savait pas quoi faire.
Elle devait être notre attraction phare.
J'ai accroché un panneau
« Hors service. Revenez hier ! »
(Rires)
C'était encore plus drôle que la boue,
alors on a laissé le panneau, pour toujours.
Des Boules de Mammouths.
Ça pèse 3 kg pièce, ces machins !
(Rires)
Du répulsif à Barbares.
C'est rempli de salades, et de pot-pourri.
Tout ce que les Barbares détestent.
Des langues mortes. [Latin] [Copte]
(Rires)
Des sangsues, mini docteurs de la nature.
Et du déo Viking, en plusieurs fragrances :
Ongles des pieds, Légumes pourris, Cendre de bûcher.
Parce qu'on pense que le déo Axe
ne devrait se trouver que sur les champs de bataille,
pas sous les bras.
(Rires)
Ceci, ce sont des puces émotives pour robots.
Ainsi, les robots peuvent ressentir amour ou peur.
Notre best seller est « Schadenfreude ».
C’était tout à fait inespéré.
(Rires)
On ne pensait pas cela possible.
Mais il y a une ONG dans l'arrière-boutique.
Les enfants passent une porte de service,
et atteignent cet espace,
où ils font leurs devoirs,
écrivent des histoires, font des films.
Voilà la soirée de lancement du livre
que les enfants ont écrit.
Nous publions un trimestriel
avec les œuvres des enfants
qui viennent chez nous chaque jour après l'école.
On a des soirées de lancement.
Les enfants mangent des gâteaux,
boivent du lait dans des coupes à champagne,
et lisent leurs histoires à leurs parents.
C'est un endroit très spécial,
parce que la boutique devant est étrange.
La blague n'est pas une blague.
On ne voit pas les coutures de la fiction.
J'adore le fait qu'une petite partie de la fiction
ait colonisé le monde réel.
C'est un livre en 3 dimensions.
Connaissez-vous le mot « métafiction » ?
Cela signifie des histoires sur les histoires.
C'est l'heure de gloire de « Méta »,
la précédente était dans les années 60,
grâce aux auteurs John Barth et William Gaddis.
Mais elle est toujours omniprésente,
presque aussi vieille que l'art de raconter des histoires.
Une technique de métafiction
consiste à abolir le 4eme mur.
C'est quand l'acteur se tourne vers l'audience,
et lui dit : « Je suis un acteur,
et ceci, ce sont des élucubrations. »
Et même ces moments soi-disant honnêtes,
existent pour servir le mensonge.
Même s'ils sont supposés
poser les fondations de l'artificialité de la fiction.
Moi, je préfère l'inverse :
si je veux casser le 4eme mur,
je veux que la fiction s'évade,
et entre dans le monde réel.
Je veux que les livres soient la porte secrète
qui laisse entrer
les histoires dans la réalité.
C'est ce que j'essaye de faire avec mes bouquins.
Un petit exemple :
mon tout premier livre s'appelle
« Billy Twitters et sa baleine bleue ».
C'est l'histoire d'un gamin qui reçoit une baleine
comme animal de compagnie.
Mais c'est une punition qui détruit sa vie.
Elle est livrée en un jour par « FedUp ». [jeu de mots avec FedEx : FedUp = Excédé]
(Rires)
Il doit l'emmener à l'école.
Mais il vit à San Francisco,
et ce n'est pas une ville facile
pour les propriétaires de baleine :
beaucoup de collines,
des prix immobiliers fort chers.
C'est inouï.
Sous la couverture du livre,
que vous voyez ici, [« Hé les enfants ! Animal marin préféré»]
il y a une pub,
qui offre une période d'essai de 30 jours
d'adoption de baleine bleue.
Il suffit de nous renvoyer une enveloppe avec votre adresse,
et nous vous envoyons une baleine.
Les enfants nous écrivent.
Voici une de ces lettres :
«Cher Gens, je parie 10 balles
que vous ne m'enverrez pas de baleine !
Eliot Gannon (6 ans) »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Eliot et les enfants qui nous ont écrit
reçoivent par retour de courrier
une lettre écrite en tout petit,
d'un bureau d'avocat norvégien.
(Rires)
La lettre explique qu'à cause
d'un changement des droits de douane
leur baleine est retenue à Sognefjord,
un très joli endroit, ce fjord,
et la lettre fait des digressions
et parle de Sognefjord
de la gastronomie norvégienne.
(Rires)
Mais la lettre se termine en disant
que la baleine serait ravie d'avoir des nouvelles.
Il y a un numéro de téléphone,
(Rires)
sur lequel on peut laisser un message.
Quand on appelle pour laisser un message
sur le répondeur, qui fait un bruit de baleine et puis bip,
(Rires)
qui ressemble beaucoup à un bruit de baleine d'ailleurs.
Ils reçoivent aussi une photo de leur baleine.
Voici Randolph.
Randolph appartient à Nico.
Nico est un des premiers gamins qui nous aie jamais appelés.
Voici quelques-uns de ses messages :
Le tout premier message que Nico m'a laissé :
(Audio) Nico: Allo ? C'est Nico.
Je suis ton maître, Randolph. Bonjour.
C'est la première fois que je te parle,
et j'appellerai encore bientôt. Ciao.
Mac Barnet : Nico a rappelé, une heure plus tard.
(Rires)
Voici un autre message de Nico :
(Audio) Nico : Salut Randolph, c'est Nico.
Je ne t'ai plus parlé depuis looongtemps,
mais je t'ai parlé samedi ou dimanche.
Ouais, samedi ou dimanche.
Et je t'appelle aujourd'hui aussi,
pour dire bonjour, et savoir ce que tu fais.
Je t'appellerai sans doute demain, ou aujourd'hui.
A plus tard alors. Bye.
MB: Et c'est ce qu'il a fait. Il a appelé le jour même.
Nico a laissé 25 messages à Randolph,
pendant 4 ans.
Il parle de lui,
de sa grand-mère qu'il aime,
et de celle qu'il aime un petit peu moins,
(Rires)
des mots croisés qu'il fait.
Et puis il y a ce message,
que je vais vous laisser écouter.
Voici le message de Noël de Nico :
(Audio) [bip] Nico: Salut Randolph,
je ne t'ai pas appelé ces derniers temps. Excuse-moi.
J'étais très occupé avec l'école qui a commencé
comme tu ne sais pas, sans doute,
t'es une baleine après tout,
et je t'appelais pour te dire,
pour te souhaiter un Joyeux Noël.
Alors, Joyeux Noël Randolph,
et au revoir. Au revoir Randolph.
MB: J'ai eu Nico en ligne
il y a deux jours, justement,
après 18 mois de silence.
Sa voix a changé,
mais il a demandé à sa baby-sitter de parler aussi,
et elle a été très gentille avec Randolph.
Nico est mon lecteur idéal.
En écrivant, je forme le vœu
que mon lecteur rejoigne ce lieu émotionnel
où se trouvent mes créations.
Je me sens privilégié.
Les enfants comme Nico sont les meilleurs lecteurs,
et ils méritent les meilleures histoires que je puisse leur offrir.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)